the time has come to check out the
mobile app for conference central we
pre-built one for Android and if you
have an Android device you can also try
it out on that device please see the
instructor notes this app will work
towards a conference central instance
hosted by Udacity but remember since you
use Cloud endpoints when you develop
conference central you could also make
this at work if you recompile it towards
your conference central instance so here
is the Udacity come from Central app and
when I select it I need to select the
user account so I select one here after
that I immediately get to the main
screen which displays all the
conference's that have been registered
so here you can see all the conference's
created in the conference central
instance hosted by Udacity should a user
add a conference using the web browser
interface for example they would also
show up here since the Android device
and the web browser using the cloud
endpoints API to talk to the conference
central server when I select the
conference for example the power of cron
jobs I can also see the details for the
conference I can also see the max
attendees and that there are two seats
left which are available if I click
register I get registered to the
conference and I can see which
conferences I am registered in by this
check mark on the right and if I go back
to the conference details you can now
see that the seats available have been
decremented 21 now I have the option to
unregister from a conference and as you
can see when i do that this mark
disappears and again the available seats
are too and that's the power of Cloud
endpoints when you create your API in
this way you can access your server
application from any device let's look
in a little bit more detail on how it
works